actress Emma Stone has started a number
of hit films including the help Birdman
in la-la land and she won an Academy
Award for Best Actress in the musical
movie Rachael vise she started in the
mummy film franchise very popular she
won an Oscar for Best Supporting Actress
in the 2005 drama The Constant Gardener
so two slackers here talented team
historical drama the favorite this movie
is so good it's set in the 18th century
when Queen Anne ruled England it tells
the story of the rivalry between Lady
Sarah Churchill and Abigail Abigail mash
them as they fight for the Queen's
affection mr. Harley came to me and
asked me to betray your confidence about
what goes on between you and the Queen
and Godolphin I see what will you do
I'm not going to obviously not obviously
you may tell me of his approach to
encourage my trust and still work both
sides of the street I am a person of
honor even my station is not even if I
were the last one left in this wretched
place I would remain a lady you're
pretty when outraged
so my secrets are safe with you
all of them
all of them and then she proceeds to
shoot her in the stone and meet us at
the table I'm not giving anything away
good morning good morning you guys
morning I described this movie as Mean
Girls on steroids they're what I like so
much is a dialogue between the two of
you you go first Emma you looked at the
script and you thought what I was in
love it was it was heaven to read you
know a story like that and especially
those types of parts those beautiful
rich layered complex parts for three
women was a dream you were the only
American in the cast right it was yep
and Rachel why were you drawn to the
character of Lady Churchill I think I
think all the characters are really
interested in complicated night I know
what you mean about their the Mean Girls
comments but because there are lots of
females and the leading roles and
they're not always kind to each other
but the difference in this is it's not
about becoming the most popular girl in
the class it's about running England so
the beginning of the film I'm running
England
the queen is think she's in charge which
she's not by the end of the movie this
one taken over so it's kind of like
vying for it's very high stakes teen
girls over they know I know variety
calls it the tooth and claw dual of
elegant backstabbing that plays out
between the two cousins so describe the
power struggle between the two of you
because you come and you were sort of a
scullery maid at one point you recall
you you refer to her as scullery scraps
yeah and you were the one Rachel who was
clearly in charge and then things took a
turn yeah I'm as I mentioned as I like
to keep mentioning running England and
my cousin who is fallen for it she's an
aristocrat originally he's fallen from
grace and and she comes to court and
flatters me and so I think she I think
God is this beautiful young ingenue a
protege and I could totally totally
don't realize how powerful she is she's
no she ain't no Angelou no trouble this
was physically challenging for you how
so it was I mean it was physically fun
as well it was you know but they're just
you know Abigail my character goes
through a lot of
being slapped pushed over rolls down a
hill falls and mud gets tackled it was
just a pretty much a daily sort of
falling downstairs yeah I slapped you
there pretty huh it's not very pretty
hard yeah where the customs
uncomfortable yes we can't maybe pretend
that they were really come they were
[Laughter]
they were so beautiful
hot hot debris you I mean I think
everyone everyone has that house that
kind of feeling right that was it
that is banks but I don't expect he's my
body organs new said that these corsets
were so tough that you actually felt
that your body organs it moves I think
that's just because I'm straight up and
down and I wasn't used to cursive well
think Spanx with whale bones in them and
mom people women my legs tired yeah
breathing is but it was also guys a very
interesting time in history that's the
other thing that fascinated me because
you know you you wouldn't think that the
Queen was taking lesbian lovers back
during those times that's why I was sort
of and why not exactly right Rachel
exactly right yeah but when I saw it on
the screen I was a little like whoa yeah
yeah well that we know that there were
there are love letters between my
character and the Queen what actually
happened in private in the bedroom
obviously we don't know that the
filmmakers drunk drunk that up the
dialogue and what happened in private
between the Queen you may notice we in
the United States are been obsessed with
the British royal family huh oh yeah
given that you are from London did you
learn more about the monarchy and were
you as enthused to do it as so many of
us are I didn't know much about Queen
and I think she's not much known about
but I what's fascinating about 1700 is
that the Queen is actually I love Mike
Megan Michael but she won't actually be
able to well she actually she's gonna
try and change a lot of things through
yes sure but she's not running the
country obviously but back in 1700s like
she's the president right so she's and
she's in charge
actually as I've mentioned twice now too
since baby
it was election day and you turned 30
Congrats oh yeah I chose a new baby in
the house Congrats to you and Daniel
thank you it's a great great movie and
great to see so many women in charge
back to history yes favorite right yeah
I'm and Rachel thank you so much you
having grad some movie Thank You
favorite opens nationwide on November
23rd